guess what everybody it's time to do one
of my favorite things in the whole wide
world a little segment we like to call
question
[Music]
party question party is very simple you
guys in the audience are going to ask me
and tara questions and me and tarik are
going to answer them
and it's going to be fun like a party
which is why we call it that
so if you have a question just raise
your hand and if we call on you stand up
and ask it ask it nice and loud so we
can hear you but do not pull your mask
down
we're trying to answer questions not
spread germs
okay let's do this who has a question
for me
and tara girl in the back is back hi
hi
um sorry i'm really excited hi hi
so i was wondering what do you guys do
to be your best selves when you come out
on stage
the question was what do we do to be our
best selves when we come out on stage
great question great question i just you
know i try to like
drink a lot of water because i know i'm
about to have a lot of margaritas
yeah
i don't know you know what the right
answer is the right answer is like oh
you know i eat uh
a light
breakfast and like
have i don't know a gatorade go over my
lines and stuff no i don't well
we go backstage and we turn music up
loud and we dance hard we dance hard um
it doesn't help anything it i mean no it
doesn't because we i i can speak from i
cannot stop sweating so it's so sweaty
it's a happy sweat
i will say for me i don't get sappy a
big part of me coming to having the best
day is this job is incredible
but i get to see my pal like run the
ship
it's an amazing thing to see i'm super
proud of you thank you derek and then
cut back to me
real tight okay
[Laughter]
yeah okay who else has a question first
off i see you ty
i see you i see you ty and sparkle
jacket what
i think sometimes people come here
and they put on their best amber outfit
i got to tell you i love that [ __ ]
oh i see you hi
i see you when you're out there oh i see
you oh
wow that's some [ __ ] i would wear okay
this is not what the segment is and i'm
so sorry i'm so sorry okay hi lady who
is waving down here hi yes
hi
okay i was wondering if you guys were on
broadway what would you play like a
character
excellent question now one of us is on
broadway right
now his name is terry davis he is in a
show called freestyle love supreme
it's real
real
it's
lin-manuel miranda's show
and they freestyle rap
suggestions from the audience yes we do
and uh best believe someone will be
joining us on stage for
one of those nights
but yeah uh freestyle love supreme at
the booth theater we open officially
october 2nd
thank you for asking that question my
real answer is
i would want to be princess winifred and
once upon a mattress because i did play
princess winterfreedom once upon a match
was in high school and it was the you
know
the moment where i was yeah
you know you got like that bloodlust for
applause like that that was where that
happened i was like oh
this could feel me instead of love
you would be great
i
i always wanted to be the pirate king
and pirates of penzance oh jerry
that's fun that would be a lot of fun
i think what i would will end up doing
is writing a i'm never gonna perform on
like a role you will not like a role she
will i'm tired
doing that every night those people are
crazy it is true but uh
i would want to perform where i'm the
bad guy oh i love that i wouldn't be the
bad guy would you be the witch and the
whiz
oh yay i could you could also let me
talk to you about the wiz after this um
who else has a question
uh this lady down front hi hi
i wanted to know if you plan on doing
any more cartoon voiceovers because i
thought i heard the creek and i got
really
i've never heard of that show when it
wasn't me
or
or it was and i forgot which is worse
but i was on
i don't know
and
birdie oh big mouth
um
but that hasn't come out yet so maybe i
wasn't supposed to sit
right in trouble
but no you're right
you're right i should be doing that but
why are you wasting all this
a scratchy high register i'm wasting it
they're the only people who would like
it as children
and you
okay
you guys i'm so glad you were here okay
that's all the time we have for question
party this was great should we do it
again sometimes
[Music]
you